cross-skilled versus the world
government buggy finding the one piece
and becoming power King before Shanks
sabo's fate and reunion with the
revolutionaries including Dragon what
really happened at Mary joa and Moore
make sure to stay tuned for this insane
chapter Chiller parking within like
buggy did this chapter and smash that
like button if you want to see more
videos like this one make this the video
you join the nakama if you haven't
already by subscribing and hitting that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications so you don't miss future
one piece videos and Updates this
chapter is called let's take it and it
starts with the major death of vice
admiral T-Bone we're told the news of
this adored man's death who was adored
by both Marines and citizens is
spreading like wildfire the death we're
told sent a shock around the world but
the Navy has now revealed the cause
behind the death yet luckily it is about
to be revealed to us and it's big it's
revealed in conversation with sengoku
and turu that they don't know about the
culprit yet but they do know that the
culprits family is Overjoyed this will
make more sense in a second so Goku
continues saying the world's going to
hell and they've been stabbed in the
back by those they protect he can't
stand it it's no longer just Pirates Who
want riches if a bounty is placed on a
marine anyone would want a piece of that
of course this makes us think of cross
Guild immediately and it seems like the
genius idea that I love of putting
bounties on Marines is finally being
felt tutor explains that Pepe Kingdom
where the death occurred has over a
thousand people dying of starvation per
year poverty and money can sway people
in wild ways which is a great Point she
says she's not agreeing with the
criminal at all obviously but if that
was Buggy's goal she says Dave starkly
underestimated buggy I love how buggy
accidentally keeps being overestimated
to the point where even as a yonko
people are thinking they underestimated
him it's awesome I love it but of course
this amazing idea is having an effect
and we're finally seeing the
implications which are crazier than
might have first been imagined at first
we might have thought that pirates would
be going after the Marines for money but
now it's is potentially anyone who wants
or needs the money which could even be
good innocent people whose families are
starving this is dangerous for the
Marines not only because it's more
enemies but they're protecting these
people and so their guard will be down
and asan Goku says this can lead to
getting stabbed in the back even by weak
people the implications are insane for
sure because the Marines will start to
mistrust citizens citizens will start to
mistrust Marines and in the end the
influence and functionality of the world
government and Marines falls apart once
again love this Marine Bounty idea even
more now sengoku straight up points to
the big dilemma can they risk their
lives to save citizens if they fear
being killed by them they decide that
they must strike back at Cross Guild
quickly otherwise it will only lower
morale as explained and weaken the Navy
the implications are so hype here as we
may be seeing Admirals fight mihawk and
KO real soon I bet they are severely
regretting going after mihawk after
disbanding the warlord system and I love
it I also love this next hilarious slide
where sengoku asks where is GARP because
he wants to tell him about a new flavor
of rice cracker that came out so funny
picturing the Bromance of these op
Legends and how they get excited about
stuff like new rice cracker flavors as
the world Burns around them it is only
then that they learn GARP went with
sword to save Kobe on Pirate Island and
they freak out showing that as usual
GARP is doing whatever he wants and not
asking for permission we then see what
is pretty much the same issue but from
the cross-skilled perspective we get the
man who just looks like an ordinary dude
thinking buggy one of the kings of the
underworld and the Superstar of evil for
sending money to his family buggy is
pretty kind here saying of course he
wiped out a Navy vice admiral all by
himself and that's some evil Charisma
buggy lets us know that all the Marines
were left in shambles that day he even
points out that if they find the man in
front of him they are sure to cut off
his head but as predicted by tsuru he
did it for his family thus he's okay
even if he never sees sees his family
again it's much better than seeing them
starve to death he says but buggy says
that he should relax and he'll take care
of him the pirate way so he's even
portrayed as a robin-esque individual
despite loving to adopt the word evil it
seems like he might be saying that he'll
protect the individual just like yonkos
have been known to protect entire
countries by associating with them one
of the things when I think about yonko
is definitely protection we're then
interrupted for one of my favorite Parts
in the chapter we're told cross Guild's
trip is complete and get a flashback of
buggy telling mihawk and crocodile to
leave the ship to him since he knows
some talented shipwrights of course the
plan backfires again like with the
poster but even worse this time mihawk
and crocodile aren't even present into
buggy shock they made about a giant
buggy head to which of course mihawk and
crocodile wonder why they have to get on
a ship such as this buggy knows this is
gonna be bad when they ask him politely
to keep up appearances why don't they go
to the conference room but he is crying
at hearing this while the crew at large
is celebrating the best ship ever we
jump to the conference where we see a
very beaten up buggy head and I get the
joke but man I don't like seeing buggy
getting so badly treated even though
it's what we gotta expect at this point
I guess but it feels like Oda kind of
sensed this and gave us some great buggy
epicness soon so just wait for that but
currently buggy is begging for them just
to kill him already crocodile meanwhile
is talking about some interesting stuff
he says The public's opinion of cross
Guild is excellent and the Navy is
slowly but surely becoming more aware of
their threat and he's spot on as we just
saw their Utopia is mentioned a military
state that is not threatened by force
because they have overwhelming power one
way to get there is to obviously weaken
other powers like the world government
which they've been doing and it's not
hard to understand why mihawk would like
this because he wants to be left alone
and he could be left alone in such
Utopia no annoying Marines chasing him
anymore they need a lot of money for
this but when he hears a about wealth
and power buggy speaks his mind to the
two and is refreshing he's not just
being a quiet punching bag but asks them
are you guys still even Pirates because
they have been looking for the one piece
so half-heartedly he continues saying
that Shanks made his move they were both
on Roger's ship and for certain reasons
as we know couldn't go to laughtail
fundamentally he's talking about dreams
coming true right now he asked them what
did they want to be when they were
younger buggy says he abandoned his
dream because he was around someone like
shank so full of Promise he felt
inadequate we get a flashback to the 24
years ago on the day of the execution
conversation between buggy and Shanks
buggy is Furious saying you said you
take your own ship to lifedale someday
but Shanks at this point says he changed
his mind for Now keywords he's not
aiming for that but he'll keep being a
pirate he says this seems to be why
buggy was so upset and said he would
never be a subordinate to him because
he's a coward he was disappointed
because he really believed in Shanks and
that he could be the next King so to see
him now going for it frustrated buggy to
no end he thought that Roger wanted them
to live on his Pirates and continue his
legacy so he says again he won't forgive
Shanks for losing his treasure map and
that next time they will be enemies it
seems clear now though that he was upset
that this guy that he looked up to and
made him feel like he couldn't achieve
his dream was too scared to go after it
although we know that there has to be a
good reason that Shanks didn't go after
right away and it could be his
conversation with Roger which we weren't
privy to back to the present and buggy
is passionate he says Shanks is on the
move you can call it fate or an accident
but somehow buggy managed to get to this
status as a fear yonko like Shanks so he
cries out I too want to be the pirate
king you know you gotta respect that
despite it being buggy he has never
truly given up on his dreams and Oda
really respects that in his characters
as do most of us so he's really giving
buggy some love here he says power and
wealth they could get it all it's
honestly not a surprise so many people
follow him after this scene and speech
he says let's go get it the Pinnacle of
treasure crocodile interrupts him with
some sand it looks like and even mihawk
says he can't sweet talk them crocodile
is very rational unlike buggy and to be
honest unlike a pirate king he speaks
about not having plans or preparations
yet mihawk is shocked that buggy is
saying he's prepared to fight red hair
Blackbeard and straw hat and then a
transmitter snail is about to activate
at of course the perfect time so
everyone can hear Buggy's inspirational
passionate words and even how he talks
down to mihawk and crocodile first he
says they don't have to beat the other
uncle but outwitting them will do the
treasure is up for grabs just watch me
you'll see the power of this one word
which I assume is referring to the two
words one piece all Pirates went to see
in search of this he says and then we
hear the click and even as buggy is
being stepped on he says you guys what
did you dream of when you first set out
to see your lives roared as you never
knew if your next breath was your last
you're now a bunch of spineless cowards
for being complacent not only does he
say this to mihawk and crocodile he says
it for everyone to hear he's actually
sounding like the leader here and you
gotta love it the ability to keep
dreaming and not get realistic is in
itself a superpower that buggy is
providing cross Guild he says reach out
for the one thing you want most of all
and I'll be right there alongside you
guys he's pretty much saying screw plans
preparation the other Yoko let's just do
it and I'm here for it loving buggy
right now he says let's take the one
piece igniting the whole crew and now
crocodile and mihawk realizing what
happened are upset even sweating but
everyone else who loves to see buggy
calling their shots should smash that
like button right now if you haven't
already just saying I love how he's just
going for it and manifesting as well
even if it's not in the conventional way
and because of this moment mihawk and
crocodile will probably have to follow
suit and make this Proclamation a
reality as best they can so as to show
they have the power they want others to
believe they possess and so the
government is in bigger trouble than
ever and everyone is on the move for the
one piece right now can it get any more
hype right now that is an honest
question we then jump to the craziest
part of the chapter or the beginning of
it we jump to the revolutionaries and
it's hilarious how they see a chip and
one dude just bets that it's gonna be
Sabo it's perfect and it seems like he
just used a telescope he seems to be
eating to figure it out beforehand and
as a long time won't be spanned none of
this surprises me even Dragon Club are
there to hear the news so finally they
can clear things up because Dragon was
not happy when Sabu was thought to have
killed vivi's dad Sabo explains that
this ship he's on is a ship from Lucia
and Not only was he not on the island
when that explosion happened he has
Lucia people on his ship who he appears
to have saved as well what a boss he
explains that he couldn't Jam the signal
at the time and it could have been
intercepted so he made a noise three
times to signal that he was being
monitored he says he wasn't even on
Lucia he staged the whole thing it's
interesting to see tricks like these
still being pulled it reminds me of when
Sanjay delivered wrong information to
crocodile back in the day over snail
it's cute to see koala's reaction as
well from Angry to so worried we find
out some Lucia people even want to join
the revolutionaries which makes sense
the cause is growing which I love to see
Dragon apologizes that they went through
the trouble of saving Kuma even though
he was probably programmed to return to
marijua anytime then some huge uses set
up ivanko says you don't plan on letting
any of the officers hear this to which
Sabo says no because just hearing it
just hearing it can put your life in
danger and isn't that just the most
earth-shaking and hype lead up you know
that this news is going to change
everything in one piece he continues
saying this year's reverie was complete
chaos I'll tell you everything he says
that happened at the holy land of
marijuana and you know it's gonna be the
biggest news where insured by the
narrator that it is not a tease since
they say the truth will be revealed and
so we will no doubt be privy to it and I
can't wait now every yank was going
after the one piece and if you want to
know everything you need to know about
the hypest of One Piece groups you don't
want to miss my all Yoko and their
powers explained video link on screen
right now